hey everyone this is justin Calvert with
gamespot at e3 2014 I'm here with my
colleague mr. Randolph Ramsey and we've
just been to see blood borne from from
software so Randy tell us about it uh so
we saw maybe about I want to say half an
hour of gameplay yes I minutes or so
yeah 20 minutes or so and it felt very
Souls to me uh it was you know it had a
lot of the hallmarks of the series so it
you know it was all about you know
monsters hiding in really annoying
places and jumping out at you you know
just like base level monsters you know
being quite difficult to overcome and
you know a lot of the the same type
elements like I think didn't actually
explain this but it seemed like there
was souls that were coming bears I was
wondering about the game of the game
still in alpha so it's super early but
yet when you were killing enemies they
were definitely still there was still
the animation of like the soul coming up
and you kind of absorbing it but then
there wasn't any kind of on-screen
indication that you were amassing souls
yeah it was huddle asst for the most
part and also saw like drops you know
those little glowing orbs that some
enemies sort of live line in the soul
series you also saw that and you know
the character sort of moved in a similar
way as you know other like other Souls
characters he moved a little bit quicker
though did you feel the same way he you
know he moved a lot quicker than my
characters do in the souls games but my
characters always carry a big shield so
he what he was carrying with the core
like a transforming saw or a
transformable saw yeah which the the
best way I think to describe is like a
giant cutthroat razor yeah which and you
can use it like you can use it while
it's closed like it's still kind of
sharp and that that attack seemed a lot
quicker but then when he would open it
up and like it became almost like a big
scythe right and then it was obviously a
bit more unwieldy but you gained a lot
of range like the aesthetic is all this
kind of Victorian Gothic as this huge
kind of fictional city I think there's
some kind of plague that's turning
people into monsters monster / zombie
things and they look like there's a
little like just number wise is just
like so many of them i'm more than i
think i can never remember seeing any of
the souls games that's normally just two
or three enemies that are going to like
beat the [ __ ] Eddie there's definitely
that sense of dread as well and I guess
you know one of the other key things
that they mentioned was how the let the
levels were going to be structured so
you know they took us through like one
path through the town and then we
managed to sort of backtrack and find a
shortcut which made us easier to get to
the point that we're at before which is
a very reminiscent of how I guess dark
souls was was structured and in more
duct cells light stuff they also hinted
at some unique online integration but
they didn't go into too much detail they
don't we talk about it yeah yeah so this
is a ps4 exclusive it's yeah it's
blood-borne and it's coming to the
PlayStation 4 in 2015 yeah and it has a
lot of blood in it